salamualikum' when I met you I better
care to pose this isn't dear friends
online EFT we have Jacob handsome man
charismatic his defense is impregnable
on my right we have a boy jockey so we
have my mini jab and Paulo Jacob Jacob
are smoking some couple of weeks ago
about contingency and he just wants to
ask me some questions I'm gonna be back
I'll give it to him I'll give it to him
so can you introduce yourself tell me
what who you are what you support what
your background is and why you wanted to
talk to me I've been wanting to meet a
little bit of a fan boy and I disagree
with pretty much everything he says but
in terms of a sort of intellectually
debating type fella he's a bit of a bit
of a hero of mine especially after
watching to be honest I don't fit cosmic
skeptic corazon in that the paper
reviews to be honest with general
non-believer libertarian nationalist
type as well but against against anyone
who's to support violence well i think i
find that i reconcile I love Tommy very
easily although he's a violent person
nothing yet he made some mistakes in his
past but I think he's a very good man I
think he's fighting for England as I do
for a lot of someone who's described me
as a hero and Tim Robinson is a urinal
is a very possible in very different
whoa all right so you said you read my
book
I wanna come inside so what kind of
we'll talk about Kalam cosmological
arguments well I'll make the kind of
what's referred to as the argument of
contingency yeah - yeah
what Leibniz is who kind of he's my main
proponent now yeah well Aristotle had
his own version right the Greeks had
their own version yet the Arabs and then
the Enlightenment all right so what were
your thoughts on the argument can you
summarize what you understand from okay
so as I understand it thank you it's
sort of it's basically Aquinas its Third
Way isn't it he's I think it's his third
way he says he he says I think yeah and
I'm glad that sort of adapted it from
him he says there are contingent things
or possible existences in this world and
obviously everything needs to have some
sort of cause otherwise it wouldn't be
contingent and this must be basically a
chain of causality terminating in a
necessary being and we the Christian or
the Muslim cause that being God correct
me nervous yes you're right some extent
there are two ways there's two ways of
doing contingency right one of them is
through causality and the other one is
through explanation that's traditionally
so in other words there the contingency
argument or what I think I think it is a
Kalam cosmological argument as well yeah
I disagree with that yeah there's a
difference of opinion on either way it
can either be done from close ality or
it can be done through a explanation it
doesn't need causation right but yeah
you could go through that way and say
okay well if you believe in there's an
effect
a priori as well as cosmologically like
in other words things in the
cosmological environment which are
affected by something have a course a
phenomena which has something that
brought rise to it which is the textbook
definition of the course hi basically
has a course that phenomena has a cause
if you believe in that a priori or if
you believe in that even from a
cosmological perspective you could argue
that well then they have to have a first
cause or whatever right but that's not
the only way of doing contingency so you
can do it through dependents as well
yeah yeah so what what do you think
about their argument about the
dependency one yeah yeah so I separate
that by the way from the clan the kalam
I hold to be the sort of traditional one
the Craig popularized the sort of you
whatever it begins to exist as cause
universe began to exist therefore
therefore God basically and then the
contingency one I think I think it's
stronger to be honest of you I mean the
Kalam really is on shaky ground on both
its premises but the contingency one is
more it's much more impressive because
at face value it does seem as if okay
you know an infinite regression seems
incompatible with everything that we
understand about the world and so it
sort of it seems very reasonable to say
yes this this must terminate somewhere
in necessity I think it's a bit of a
leap that they then call that God so
people like David Toombs said no why
can't it be I think I was using the
persona of Cleon theis he said like
although he said he says first to his
debate he says first first of all you
know you're assuming that there is
something necessary being a no hehe t he
doubts whether you can even use the term
necessary with us having any coherent
meaning and then he says okay suppose
suppose there is he says why can't this
just be the totality of the universe and
then so for me there's several issues
with it it says for one if there is
something necessary okay it could just
be the totality of all that exists I
realize there's problems with analyst
per implanted pattern argument you make
one could simply be that there that
there are just contingent things okay
and it doesn't seem like sort of logical
you know 100% that there must be
something necessary see well I say these
are the two main the other problem is
from an objective is going to be right
we might say you know necessary could is
anything that you you couldn't conceive
like you couldn't conceive otherwise
like some people say no the planet
Jupiter is actually necessary and you
might say are you can conceive of a
planet Jupiter not being there I can you
really is impossible to I'm not sure if
you can conceive of a universe in which
there are things that are not there
which leads me to believe maybe there
are more than one necessary existences
so that's about three arguments in one
all right so the first thing you
mentioned was that the first thing you
mentioned was the the William Lane Craig
types of modes both he wrote a book in
79 called Kalam cosmological argument
why would he still Carolyn because words
go give us so with that the reason why I
called it that is to show that this is
not one argument right they wonder
William Lane Craig focuses on is the has
alien was but even as early in his most
famous book at horrific philosopher
which is the incoherence of the
philosophers good even he he postulates
more than one argument which is so he
makes an argument from movement which is
quite similar to you talking about - he
says look he says that
for example this is one of his other
because you talked about one of his
arguments he mentioned it someone of his
book he says everything that begins to
exist has a cause the universe began to
die l'm by the way the universe is not a
good translation of what the hell he
actually said he says the world hasn't
began to exist not the universe the
universe is a new term right so he says
Allah eylem
or the the world began to exist
therefore the world hasn't course right
so it William Lane Craig latched on to
this he makes all his make if you see
William Lane Craig argue that's he
that's like necessarily made that
argument and more than that argument so
for example he said look one of his
arguments I made which is also a
cosmological argument because a
cosmological argument is an argument
that makes reference to the cosmos
literally to the world around us he said
look he said that movement is really
what is its time and movement the time
has paid he says look he says that if
you believe in movement he made an
argument for movement the first mover
argument which is the same argument as I
started to say if you believe in time he
believed in movement so long as there is
time there is movement and if there is
and if and if there is movement there
must be a mover that's another argument
right so the argument i Rossella made
the argument has Allah made the argument
I V Sanders didn't reject the argument
what Abby said is not about that in his
book he said look he suggests if you eat
and this is a good point I'll be son I
said just because there's a first mover
it doesn't necessarily
is the cause of everything that exists
yes so you can believe in a DA stick
first mover yeah you can believe in the
Albert Einstein grab anyway the first
mover argument may it may give us
evidence that there were there was in
fact a first mover or an eternal mover
however it doesn't give us evidence that
that move has intelligence without that
mover is equivalent to make chart from
the isn't it absolutely yes now all of
the argument look I'll be frank with you
the maximum we can prove from a logical
perspective is deistic really
yeah if you put a look if you if you
define theism as a as a personal God
then you cut there's no real first
principles you can use to establish them
here's what we say we say as Muslims is
that our fundamental foundational
definition of God doesn't depend
necessarily on a personal God that's
additional information that we've got
Christian yeah
that's additional information that we
only come to know it's so facto through
revelation so look the necessary causes
this everything in the world is
dependent whether like this book is
dependent on the materials oh whatever
and it goes back and you can't have that
process not going back to something
which is necessary in other words
something which does not depend on
anything else simply simple as that so
you have to have an independent to have
all other dependent things if you want
to simplify the argument to the lowest
common multiple you have to have an
independent to have all other
dependencies what are the attributes of
that independent that independent must
be eternal because it couldn't be
conceived of any other way at any other
time so it has to be like that forever
in the past put a pre-eternal and
post-eternal it has to be necessary in
the fact that it can't be conceived of
any other way and it has to be this has
to be the reason for everything else
that exists the ultimate reason so your
objection that you mentioned about the
universe being the universe it's not
actually an objection because all you're
doing is you're saying that I believe in
an unnecessary since Canon can be can
exist what that necessary existence
could be the universe
so someone could say okay well so you
agree with the premise of the argument
that you just agree with the nature of
the necessary existence
so really the postulation which is what
Bertrand Russell kind of alluded to
himself and others as well that you know
the universes is the necessary existence
is not I think it comes from yes because
he came before but you the point is that
if you say that it's not a rejection of
the argument then you see the point so
you accept the argument but you just
have a different nature you have a
different understanding of what could be
right yes I wouldn't use the word go out
the necessary so at this point that's
not a rejection it's not it's not an
objection to the argument or a rejection
of the ugh yeah you agree the argument
but it's okay it could be the universe
oh no problem so now we won't rule the
universe out but for now we'll explain
why it won't be the universe in a second
right but for now but let's agree that
first of all you accept that there must
be a necessary existence